thank you very much for being on the
program uh this morning so last July
Rishi Scenic laid out a 10-point plan to
tackle illegal migration how's that
going
well we've made a lot of progress in a
short period of time we've already
lented into really unique Landmark deals
with France which are seeing a big
increase in the number of interceptions
on the beaches 33 000 migrants were
stopped Crossing as a result of that
last year a 40 percent increase on the
year before we've entered into a gold
standard arrangement with Albania that
is seeing thousands of Albanian legal
migrants returned home and the numbers
Crossing from that country significantly
reducing we've just entered into an
agreement with Georgia we've entered
into one with Italy and on the domestic
front we've increased the amount of
illegal working visits like raids on car
washes and nail bars and so on by 50
percent this year alone all to make it
harder to operate in the UK If you're
either an illegal migrant or one of the
people smuggling gangs and just this
week I've been in North Africa in
countries like Tunisia and Algeria area
taking the fight to the people smuggling
gangs Upstream before people have even
got close to the UK okay we're
increasing the resources of Our National
Crime agency through operation and vigor
so that they have the resources to smash
the gangs and organized immigration
crime so on every front we're taking
action and we're starting to see the
results of that in the numbers crossing
the Channel I want to unpick some of
what you've said a little later in the
interview just to try and work out you
know exactly the progress that is being
made
But first you recently said in a speech
that people who arrive in the UK on
small boats are cannibalizing our
communities
what what do you mean by that well I
didn't say that what I said was that
they risk cannibalizing The Compassion
of the UK public because what we're
seeing with the small boats is a very
large number of mostly young men leaving
safe countries like France often having
passed through multiple safe countries
coming to the UK and then requiring
immense resource here to accommodate to
support and to integrate them what do
you mean by the word cannibalizing
though why don't you choose that word
it's a very eye-catching word well I
think it's the right it's the right
terminology that the illegal migration
challenge the small boats crisis is
making it harder for the UK to do what
we really want which is to support
people who are genuinely seeking the
support of the United States you're
saying it's making it harder for the UK
to do what they want but use the word
cannibalizing what does you mean by
cannibalizing because with small boats
you're finding that tens of thousands of
young men who are in a place of safety
who are predominantly economic migrants
are coming to the UK putting
overwhelming pressure on our Asylum
system and on the compassion generosity
of the British public and making it then
harder for us to support people who
genuinely need our help and what we want
to do as a government is devote our
finite resources to helping families and
those people who are in Conflict zones
by continuing to do world-class
resettlement schemes like homes for
Ukraine the Syrian and Afghan scheme by
doing our Global scheme that works with
the United Nations to take people out of
refugee camps and bring them in a
controlled manner to the UK if you allow
uncontrolled illegal migration to
escalate then I'm afraid the British
public will find it harder to support
people who genuinely need our help and
that is why we're taking the very robust
steps that we are to get this problem
under control so let's see how you are
going to know the problem under control
what's the current backlog for Asylum
claim processing well there's over 150
000 cases in the backlog but we've made
a very clear pledge to eliminate the
Legacy backlog over the course of this
year we made that pledge at the end of
last year and the Prime Minister the
home section I put in place a robust
plan which is now working you say it's
now working there's a number of cases in
the Legacy fall let's have a look you
know Asylum applications Awakening
decision like you're talking about
Legacy there most people just look at
the overall cases it might be one thing
that you're starting to bring the Legacy
down but if the overall numbers are
going up that's different you can see
there's been a small fall between 2020.
I think most people would look at this
and not think that this is a system
that's under control do you accept that
uh I think the system needs robust
reform and that's exactly what we're
setting out to do we are putting in
place processes to streamline the way
decisions are taken to simplify remove
all the bureaucracy that has crept up in
recent years to double the number of
caseworkers making the decisions over
the course of this year and that is
beginning to have results as you can see
on the screen and I'm confident that we
will eliminate the Legacy backlog but
the key thing to note here is that the
sustainable answer to this challenge is
to reduce the number of people crossing
in the first place I've just been to a
number of European countries
of cases but the way to stop this
problem is not to focus solely on the
symptoms of it but is to focus on the
cause and that's why I'm saying the bill
that we're taking through Parliament if
I may um the backlog is one element of
this another element is the number of
people who have been removed from the UK
um 38 000 failed Asylum Seekers and
foreign criminals removed from the UK
last year that's the newest number on
record other than the pandemic years
well if you look at the stats for the
beginning of this year which is the
period after the Prime Minister home
section I put in place our plan we're
actually seeing returns back to
pre-pandemic levels and we want them to
rise we've signed an agreement with
Albania which is absolute best in class
we signed number one now with George
let's talk about Albania then shall we
because as you say so many people uh it
did make up quite a large proportion of
people arriving on small boats so how
many you made a big play of the returns
agreement you struck with Albania so how
many people who've arrived on small
boats have been returned to Albania uh
well thousands of albanians are
returning to Albania I just want to I
just want to split that because I know
that foreign criminals are part of these
numbers as well many of those have also
if we're just talking about originally
if we're just talking about people
arriving on some more boats how many
have been returned to Albania well there
are hundreds of albanians who've arrived
on small boats who have been placed on
those flights as a result of the
processes we put in place and the
agreements that we've reached with
Albania and you only have to look at
what's happening hundreds uh how many
people at this point Sophie I know I'm
just trying to get you well if you only
have to look at what's happening to the
number of albanians making this thing
this is a different point because the
two are related
specifically is to deter people from
coming in the first place and that is
succeeding if I may I'm specifically
asking about the number of albanians
who've arrived on small boats who have
been returned under the agreement to be
completely onto you I'm trying to get to
the bottom about whether you're trying
to Cloud these figures is by focusing on
foreign criminals who've been returned
to Albania or whether this deal that you
struck with Albania is actually working
well the the foreign offenders in most
cases are being returned under the
arrangement because what happens and
this is why we need to reform the system
is that even after serving a sentence in
our prisons an offender will then put in
an asylum came they may then also claim
to be a victim of modern slavery they
make spurious last minute uh claims and
appeals to frustrate our ability to
remove them and that's why we reach this
agreement with Albania and so that we
can remove them
it is right that we focus on foreign
National offenders you know of course we
want to remove people who have come
across on small boats but we also should
be getting people out of our prisons who
have committed serious crimes sure
returning them I don't think well-being
yeah I don't think anyone is wrong to
allow those people I don't think anyone
back into British Society I don't think
any animals dispute in that I'm just
trying to work out how effective the
Albania returns deal is
of the number of albanians who've
arrived on small boats how many have
been returned under this gold standard
as you put her agreement well I said
hundreds have been returned
well it doesn't happen to the rest of
them well if you've got this returns
agreement that means they can just click
the things it was relatively early days
had they just disappeared it's
relatively early days but also you only
have to look at the numbers now
attempting to cross what's happened to
the others what's happened to the other
albanians then are they in hotels or do
you not know where they are uh some of
them are being accommodated some have
returned home voluntarily and some may
well have absconded but that is
absolutely the reason why we're taking
this action so because why are there
still albanians in hotels in the UK
there were very few we're working
through those cases and removing them
but what you're getting to the nub of
the question here which is that our
system has become riddled with uh legal
processes which enable people to make
Furious last minute it appeals even the
Lord chief justice recently made this
point that's why we're putting in place
the illegal migration bill that cuts all
of this process out in the first place
and is based on the very simple
principle that if you come across in a
small boat you have no right to live or
make a life in the UK you'll either be
returned home swiftly to a safe country
like Albania or you'll be returned to a
safe Third Country like Rwanda and you
won't be able to use our legal system or
misuse our legal system in order to
frustrate your removal if we can do that
we will break the people smuggling gangs
we will deter people from Crossing in
the first place and with respect to
Albania you only have to compare the
proportion of those people crossing the
channel in the first quarter of last
year to the first quarter of this year
to see that this has been hugely
effective in creating the deterrent
effect that we set out to okay let let's
talk about the covered inquiry shall we
and the government's launched a legal
challenge so it doesn't have to hand
over unredacted WhatsApp messages to the
covert inquiry what's it got tied
we want to hand over to the covert
inquiry absolutely anything that has
anything to do with covid-19 or the
purpose of the inquiry and that's the
right thing to do this is an important
inquiry and we want Lady Justice Hallett
and her team to have access to all the
information that they need
where there is a point of difference is
that we don't think that it's sensible
or reasonable to hand over documents or
messages that have nothing whatever to
do with covid-19 and I'm a former lawyer
I've been involved in Discovery requests
from courts in the past and the normal
way to do this is to set reasonable
parameters to request anything that is
related to the case
or in this situation the inquiry but not
to ask for things that are wholly
unrelated nothing was ever to do with
the inquiries to decide that if you had
that then they can decide what's
relevant as a lawyer having been
involved in in Discovery in the past
that's not common practice but it may
not be common practice but this is an
exceptional set of circles well I can't
think of any situation where a court
would ask for
documents or messages that have
absolutely nothing to do with the
purpose of the case or the inquiry I
mean for example things to do with a
civil servant or indeed a politician's
private life that are wholly unrelated
but do not trust the inquiry to decide
what's relevant well there's no question
about whether we trust the inquiry or
not we have the highest regard for Lady
Justice hallerton her team we're not
asking for special treatment for the
government what we're saying is that we
should uphold common legal practice
which would be applied in any civil case
in the British courts and should be
applied to this inquiry we think that's
very reasonable I hope that this can be
resolved indeed before it matter even
gets to court and we want to continue to
cooperate productively with Lady Justice
Hallett to resolve it Forrest Johnson of
course bypassing the cabin offer to send
his whatsapps directly to the inquiry
why do you think he's doing that
well it's it's entirely up to the former
prime minister how he cooperates with
the inquiry if he wishes to send his uh
documents or WhatsApp messages to them
then he's he's at Liberty to do so I
think a letter has been sent from the
cabin office to him to say that as he is
using taxpayers funds to pay for his
lawyers then that funding has to be used
for appropriate purposes but he can
advance whatever arguments he wants to
and make whatever statements he wishes
in his witness statement to the inquiry
there's absolutely no sense that the
government will uh restrict what Boris
Johnson wants to say but if you use
taxpayers funds obviously you should
make sure you're using them
appropriately I mean some would say that
this comes down to the relationship
between ports Johnson and Russia maybe
not the most helpful course of action
for the former prime minister to take
and allies of Boris Johnson have told
them on Sunday that they think the
number reason number 10 doesn't want to
share their messages is because it could
reveal what you see next plotting to
bring down Boris Johnson no as I say the
the issue here is a simple legal one
which is should you hand over material
to an Inquirer which has absolutely
nothing to do with covid-19 and that's a
long-standing practice in British courts
I think it's fair and reasonable that
that's applied to the inquiry as well
and I hope that we can resolve this with
Lady Justice Hallett very soon now you
famously wrote a piece back in 2019
backing Boris Johnson I think have a
look at it along with two faces who
might be quite familiar to our viewers
you can sort of look in their Rishi
sunak Prime Minister Oliver Dowd and the
former prime minister do you regret
backing Boris Johnson no it was the
right decision at the time the country
was facing a very serious challenge we
needed to get brexit done to end the
paralysis that there was in Parliament
at the time and to stop the labor party
led by Jeremy corbyn from taking over
our country so I'm sure all three of us
fully support that decision but look we
have a great prime minister today in
British sunak he's getting on with the
challenges facing the country and I
fully support him I mean you all look a
bit more fresh-faced back then I think
before the sort of political roller
coaster that we've all been on uh Russia
is the next prime minister now of Oliver
darden's Deputy Prime Minister and when
you keep backing the right horse Boris
Johnson then Rishi sunak a bit
disappointed not to be a secretary of
state
look I it's entirely up to the Prime
Minister who who he appoints to which
job I'm I've always taken on difficult
and challenging roles this is certainly
one of them but it's one that matters to
the public the public want to see us
secure our borders to stop the boats and
that's what I'm working very hard with
the homes actually with the prime
minister to deliver